Transcription: Willow Bushell
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il n’y a pas si longtemps,
j’étais là,
dans le même fauteuil que vous,
dernière année d’études,
à me demander :
«Mais qu’est-ce que je vais faire
de ma vie ?»
Alors, il y en a peut-être parmi vous
qui sentent l’angoisse monter rien
qu’à l’évocation de cette question.
Pas de panique.
Je suis passée par là
et je pense m’en être plutôt bien sortie.
Décembre 2020,
je lance ma chaîne TikTok.
«Mais Yoline, TikTok, c’est un réseau
social pour les adolescents.
Ce n’est que des vidéos de danse
sans intérêt.
Qu’est-ce que tu vas faire là-dessus ? »
J’ai envie de devenir la grande sœur
que j’aurais rêvé d’avoir
à 15, 18, 20 ans.
Dire ce que j’aurais aimé
qu’on me dise à cet âge-là.
Partager mes conseils, mon expérience
dans les relations amoureuses,
dans la confiance en soi.
«Mais... tu n’as pas peur
de t’exposer au regard des gens ? »
Je vous rassure tout de suite,
si vous vous lancez
sur les réseaux sociaux,
votre première vidéo ne fera pas
1 million de vues.
Si déjà 10 personnes la voient,
c’est très bien.
La vérité, c’est que...
On se fiche pas mal
de ce que pense @Maxime62,
qu’importe l’avis d’inconnus sur nous.
Nous avons peur de l’avis
de nos proches sur nous,
ceux qui nous connaissent vraiment.
Vont-ils nous juger si on échoue ?
Vont-ils encore nous aimer ?
Mais, surtout,
est-ce que, moi, je vais encore m’aimer
si j’échoue ?
La réponse à cette question
est très simple.
Au moins, j’aurais essayé.
Quoi qu’il arrive, j’aurais essayé.
Et ça, personne ne pourra jamais
vous l’enlever.
Vous aurez donné une chance
à votre ambition.
C’est la plus belle preuve d’amour
que vous pouvez vous faire à vous-même.
Septembre 2021,
fraîchement diplômée de l’EM Lyon,
je viens de terminer mon projet
de fin d’études entrepreneuriales.
J’ai adoré travailler sur ce projet.
J’ai envie de tenter l’aventure,
de me lancer dans l’entrepreneuriat,
de donner une chance à ce projet.
Tous mes amis partent à Paris,
premier CDI,
premier appartement,
premier salaire,
sorties.
Pour moi, c’est retour chez Papa et Maman.
« Tu veux te lancer ? Très bien.
On te loge mais tu te débrouilles. »
OK. Je relève le défi.
Mon business plan sur trois ans
de 50 pages est prêt.
Et...
Et maintenant ?
Par où je commence exactement ?
La montagne paraissait insurmontable.
C’est là que vient
le premier abandon.
Attention, ne vous méprenez pas,
Ce n’était pas l’abandon de mon projet,
je suis bien plus coriace que ça.
Mais l’abandon
de l’idée que je me faisais de mon projet,
de cette image parfaite
que j’avais construite dans ma tête.
J’ai compris que, pour commencer,
il fallait que j’accepte
d’être à l’étape un.
Alors je tombe, je trébuche,
je fais plein d’erreurs.
Je culpabilise, j’aimerais en faire moins.
Mais que m’apporte cette culpabilité ?
Vous pensez que Kylian Mbappé
n’a jamais raté de but de sa vie ?
Surtout à ses débuts ?
Bien sûr que non.
J’ai compris que, pour commencer,
il fallait accepter
d’être imparfait.
Alors OK, je suis à l’étape un.
Je...
Je démarche les incubateurs,
je présente mon projet
à un tas de personnes,
je postule à des bourses.
Et pourtant,
personne ne veut croire en mon projet.
C’est difficile.
L’incompréhension se mêle à la solitude.
Tant de travail investi
pour si peu de retours.
Février 2022.
Toujours dans le flou.
La Saint-Valentin arrive à grands pas.
Je sens, dans ma communauté,
une sorte d’appréhension monter :
majoritairement des célibataires
à qui je donne mes conseils en amour
appréhendent un petit peu
la Saint-Valentin.
Je me dois de réagir
et je me rappelle une idée
que j’avais lancée ici,
à l’EM Lyon,
pour m’amuser.
J’avais créé un formulaire
avec une quinzaine de questions
pour trouver le match parfait
aux étudiants.
On répondait au formulaire
et en fonction des compatibilités,
je matchais les gens.
Et si...
D’ailleurs,
petite parenthèse, certains devraient
me remercier pour ça aujourd’hui.
Et si je faisais la même chose
avec mes abonnés ?
Peut-être qu’ils auraient quelqu’un
à qui parler le soir de la Saint-Valentin.
Et pourquoi pas trouver l’amour ?
Alors je crée ce petit formulaire.
Je le lance sur mes réseaux sociaux
sans grande attente
et je l’appelle le YOYOMATCH
en référence à mon compte Instagram,
Yoyobdt_.
Et là...
C'est le choc.
En quelques heures, le YOYOMATCH
prend une ampleur folle.
Je suis complètement dépassée
par la situation.
Des milliers de personnes s’inscrivent.
Je commence à recevoir des dizaines
et des dizaines de messages.
Waouh !
Tout est devenu clair.
Le YOYOMATCH était le projet
sur lequel je devais me concentrer.
J’avais ressenti tellement de plaisir,
tellement de joie
à le créer,
à divertir,
et, le 14 février,
à recevoir tous ces messages de gratitude,
de remerciements,
pour une Saint-Valentin réussie.
C'était ça qui m'avait rendue heureuse.
«Mais Yoline,
tu vas vraiment abandonner le projet
sur lequel tu as travaillé
pendant des mois et des mois,
pour te concentrer sur le YOYOMATCH ?»
La réponse était oui.
Sans hésiter.
Qu’importent le temps
et le travail investis.
Personne ne vous force à rester
sur un chemin qui ne vous correspond plus.
La seule personne qui vous contraint,
c’est vous-même.
Et si vous changez de chemin,
ne pensez pas que le précédent
était un mauvais choix,
bien tout le contraire.
C’est grâce à ce chemin
que vous avez pu découvrir
ce que vous vouliez vraiment.
C’est parce que vous êtes passé par là
que vous avez pu savoir
où vous vouliez aller.
Ce serait de la folie pure de nier
ce que vous savez maintenant
et de vous contraindre
à rester sur ce chemin.
Aujourd’hui,
je réalise que cette aventure
entrepreneuriale me pousse chaque jour
à cultiver de l’indulgence
et de la compassion envers moi-même.
Le YOYOMATCH continue de se développer.
Je reçois des photos
et des vidéos de couples
qui sont aujourd’hui ensemble
grâce au YOYOMATCH
et j’ai même organisé
mon premier événement
en collaboration avec le Paris Basket-ball
le 2 novembre dernier.
Le premier YOYOMATCH en live.
Quelle aventure!
Quel que soit votre chemin,
osez faire des choses
qui sortent de l’ordinaire,
que vous n’avez jamais faites avant.
Autorisez-vous à être imparfait
et aussi donnez-vous la permission
de changer d’avis.
Vous êtes libre de vous écouter.
Mais enfin,
retenez qu’il n’y a pas
de destination finale à atteindre.
Vous êtes et vous serez
toujours sur le chemin.
Alors autant le tracer selon vos envies.
Merci.
(Applaudissement)